I am Deanna klingman I am a professional
learning specialist with Khan Academy
hello everyone my name is Stacy Johnson
I lead professional learning for Khan
Academy today we are going to explore
how conmigo can support you and save you
time so whether you already have con
Amigo and are looking for some tips or
maybe you're just wondering what is
conmigo and how can it help you we're
here we're here to talk to you about
that today and we have you covered all
right so as we know right now ai is all
around us there are several tools on the
market that's designed to support
teachers so you're probably asking what
make what makes kamigo so different
so we keep accuracy safety and
responsible data management at the
Forefront of every decision that we make
we're also adhering to those National
and Regional guidelines so that the
Learners as well as the teachers
have the best experience more than that
the one thing that I really love about
comigo is that it's designed to also
work with the Khan Academy content so
now you as an educator have a
comprehensive Suite of resources that's
going to support your lesson planning
data analysis and just resources that
are going to allow you to be able to
tailor the needs of your tailor to the
needs of your students
headlines like we've all seen them and
so as you continue to see these
headlines we know that you have a wide
range of emotions as we just kind of
talked about before from excitement to
apprehension and we want to acknowledge
those feelings AI has some exhilarating
potential it's Revolution
revolutionizing Fields like Health Care
communication and education
however we do know that there are some
concerns around AI concerns about Job
displacement privacy and you know some
ethical considerations and these are
valid emotions
however it is important to separate fact
from fiction so AI is a tool it's not
meant to replace that human interaction
that we know is very important is
designed to assist not to take over
here at Khan Academy the way we use AI
we talk about it as a way to support the
teacher not replace the teacher it's
going to help you as the teacher save
time help you tailor your lessons and
expedite planning so you can do what you
do best and we know that's working with
students
we are at the cusp of using AI for
probably the biggest transformation that
education has ever seen we're going to
give every teacher on the planet an
amazing artificially intelligent
teaching assistant that is a quote
directly from our leader Sal Khan
as a non-profit organization we see it
as our duty to explore ai's potential
for education's future we believe AI can
positively transform learning but we're
also aware of some of those risks right
we're focused on insurance ai's benefits
making sure that it's shared equally
across society and we're committed to
those ethical and ethical and
responsible development process
we also want to be very transparent in
this presentation about costs we know we
know most of you are wondering okay well
how much does it cost and who can use
conmigo
teachers parents adult Learners and
school districts can all get conmigo on
the screen you do see some prices there
and at the end of this presentation
we're going to make sure that you get
more information about how to access and
purchase comigo
we are most of the times we get uh
specific questions around comigo and so
we want to address a few of those right
now
first we know that Khan Academy is known
for providing a free world-class
education but we do have to charge for
comigo
because we have to cover the fees that
we have to pay for GPT for
in order for a teacher to give their
students access the teacher must be a
part of a district partnership as a way
to prioritize student safety
we'll have more information on the
Partnerships later in this presentation
if you are a homeschooling parent you
can you can only get access for your
child only
and we would love to have a free trial
um for t for educators who would like to
however we do have some technical
limitations that prevent that option at
this time
so you might be wondering where the name
kamigo comes from we've combined uh our
name Khan with the Spanish word Amigo
which now gives you a creative co-pilot
that's going to work alongside with you
and it has a very welcoming and
supporting presence
um available as you are going through
your Khan Academy Journey
all right so with that it is time to
jump into conmigo
so I'm going to be working in the
platform today walking you through some
of the things that you can see
experience and what it might be like to
use this with students in the classroom
so I just logged into my Khan Academy
account and this page is the first page
that pops up this is our AI activities
page there is lots of stuff here and
we're going to dig into a few of these
in a little bit but I want you to just
first notice that there are activities
here that support teachers we can look
at how our students are doing in Khan
Academy with a class snapshot we can
refresh our knowledge co-create a rubric
even chat with chatgpt4 there are also
some activities down here that allow you
to take the seat of a learner and we're
going to dig into all of that but there
is lots of stuff here and I just want
you to notice right out of the gate how
much you have at your fingertips with
conmigo
but we do have this AI activities page
but my favorite part the real power in
my mind of conmigo is using conmigo with
our courses
so I'm going to go up here in this top
left hand menu of our screen in Khan
Academy I'm going to open up the courses
menu and what you see here if you're not
already familiar we have courses in
mathematics science Arts and Humanities
if you're looking for middle school
science or high school history we have
courses that tailor to all of those
needs
so conmigo what makes conmigo different
is that it partners with this already
well-known high quality content to
really create a comprehensive learning
path and support for all students
so I'm going to show you what that looks
like by jumping into our middle school
biology class I'm going to go into
middle school biology
and what we see here we have all of
these units on the left hand side so
this has the same sort of arrangement as
a textbook this is a course and each
course is made up of a series of units
I'm going to scroll down here on this
screen we can see the units here too and
each unit is made up of lessons I'm
going to jump into the first lesson here
cells and organisms
and what we see here is that we have all
sorts of content to support Learners we
have videos articles and exercises so
I'm going to go into an exercise I'm
going to be working with my students
next week on understanding cells and
organisms and conmigo is down here in
the corner so if I'm getting ready to
teach this content to my students I'm
going to open up conmigo
and as a teacher it has several
different prompts here that I can use to
support my instruction and my planning
so the first that I want to do is how
might I explain this concept to my
students what does it mean to teach
cells and organisms and making sure
students understand that so I'm going to
click here to help me explain this
concept open that up a little bit bigger
so you can see it
and conmigo is going to give me some
ideas of how I might talk to my students
about cells and organisms
quite an explanation here so we started
with like hey kiddos today how we're
going to talk about something super cool
cells and organisms
but maybe I was looking for something a
little bit different I'm going to ask
conmigo can you help me write a catchy
poem oops
about this for my students foreign
loves the idea of the poem cells cells
that really swell in every organism They
Do Dwell so
we can ask conmigo for different takes
on things different pieces of
information so that we can present this
to students in a way that feels relevant
and tied to what we are already doing in
instruction
so I love this because it really helps
me not only think about what content
might I deliver to students I have that
great Khan Academy content here but I
can use conmigo to help me think about
how I deliver that to my students
I'm just going to refresh this chat go
right back to the beginning
and maybe now I want to walk through
this exercise so remember we're here in
this exercise asking some questions and
I have this exercise it's just going to
be presented to students what are all
organisms made up of a single cell many
cells one or more cells so I can open up
conmigo as a teacher and have it walk me
through the exercise
let's see what it says
maybe I'm working on making sure that I
understand this maybe I'm doing this
with my kids whole class
it tells me here this is the example of
what students see here's the answer
choices and it tells me what the answer
is so maybe if I'm reviewing content
that I haven't seen in a little while or
I'm doing a math concept I don't have
the time to break out the paper and
pencil that's here as a support for me
now as a teacher you have this little
toggle up here right now I'm in teacher
mode
and in teacher mode
I'm going to get this support it's
talking to me like I'm a teacher
so I have this support of getting the
answer
walking through exactly what's explained
but if I turn that off and I go into
student mode con Amigo's going to
support me much more like a Socratic
tutor putting the ownership of learning
back on me as the learner and the
student so in student mode conmigo is
not going to provide answers so I want
you to think about this
and if you have this in your classroom
as a teacher how might you be able to
turn on student mode and maybe project
this onto the Whiteboard pull it up on
the Smart Board and turn student mode on
to engage students in a new and exciting
way maybe something that they haven't
seen before that might be exciting to
them we're going to talk more about that
in just a little bit
with that I'm going to jump over and
show you another one of my favorite
activities I'm going to go back to this
AI activities page
and I'm going to open up class snapshot
before I do that we already mentioned
that using conmigo alongside our courses
and content remember that's up here so
using conmigo with algebra 1 Algebra 2
Middle School physics is really what
makes conmigo different and makes it
stand apart from other tools on the
market so if you're using conmigo or
you're interested in using conmigo
students should also be working in Khan
Academy and learning in those Khan
Academy courses you can set your
students up with Mastery goals and
assignments so that they are working on
content that mirrors what you're already
doing in the classroom you haven't
checked it out definitely jump into the
courses and find a course and maybe
explore it on your own to see what's
here
but imagine for a second we've already
done that we've gotten our kids set up
they're working in Khan Academy and now
as a teacher I have con Migo
rather than going in and having to look
at how every single one of my students
has done and what they're working on in
Khan Academy I'm going to open up class
snapshot and I'm going to go into one of
my courses I'm going to check out my
algebra 1 course
I'm going to open that up
I'm gonna give it a second and I want
you to take a look at what class
snapshot can do
so it's pulling data for the last seven
days now my class has not been very
active but we know y'all are going to
have much more active students
what you're seeing here is the activity
and the performance of your class so I'm
seeing the activity of my students I had
a goal that they were going to work for
30 minutes I'm gonna is a little behind
the curve they've only done an average
of two minutes I see the assignments and
how my class is doing their average
exercise performance quizzes tests and
how they're doing on their skills so
imagine my students are working through
their Algebra 1 course and in a snap I
can open up con Nigo and I can get this
snapshot to see Quick Glance how are my
students doing this is really powerful
information that makes it a whole lot
easier for me to get a comprehensive
view of my classes progress I understand
where my class stands in terms of
learning objectives I can identify areas
where my students are excelling and
maybe where we have some more
opportunities for growth and extra
instruction
so I love this because it saves us Time
by giving us a Consolidated view of
class progress totally takes away the
need for manual tracking and looking at
each individual student I can always dig
in right I can always go take a closer
look at a student but this makes it
really easy for me to dig in and get
that nitty-gritty information about how
my students are doing
so after we get the class snapshot
what I really love are some options for
student grouping because it's one thing
to have this data it's another thing to
know what to do with it and how we're
going to respond and how that data is
going to be used to drive instruction
so we might ask conmigo which students
need to be celebrated for their work we
want students need that pat on the back
as much as we do
we might ask who needs a check-in about
their skills progress for the week or
who's a little ahead of the curve and
they're doing better than 25 on their
Mastery goal but what I want to show you
is how we can group the class by their
recommendations so if students have been
working on this content
how can we take those students and make
groups so I'm going to open up this tool
let's see what it comes back with
all right check it out
here's my students names and a list of
the concepts and skills that they need
to work on so I have Chelsea that needs
to work on this set of recommendations
and I have a whole group of kiddos that
need to work on these skills here so
what this is done I mean in a world past
I would have to look at every student
how they're doing on their skills figure
out where they are in those skills make
groups
and this has done that for me right it's
taking all of that data it's allowing
you to make student groups which is
super empowering saving time and now I
know what I'm doing tomorrow I'm going
to grab those students I'm going to grab
Chelsea pull her to the back get some
chart paper and we're going to talk
about relating division of
multiplication and how those go together
okay they didn't even go back into my
class and assign that content again from
those Khan Academy courses so con Migo
and Khan Academy they go hand in hand
and again that's really what sets this
tool apart it's not just a standalone AI
tool it's a tool that complements
curriculum and content in a really
powerful way
all right so with that we're going to
jump into some of these other activities
and I think you're going to be really
excited because these are pretty cool
so I'm going to start by looking at
refresh my knowledge
there are so many use cases for this
tool whether maybe we're a new teacher
and we're still working on building that
Comfort to stand up in front of a group
of students that can be a little bit
critical and deliver content to answer
questions or I remember in my eighth
year of teaching I was feeling pretty
good about myself until I was given a
brand new grade level and while I knew
the content it had been a minute and I
just needed a safe place to go and
practice and not everybody has that safe
space so conmigo and refresh my
knowledge can be there
so
here we are to start off what topic and
grade level would I like a refresher on
so I'm going to be teaching eighth grade
gene mutations oops what help if I type
the number there we go eighth grade gene
mutations
so it's going to give me some major
concepts related to gene mutations that
are going on here and then I have a
choice I can practice and build my
understanding and comprehension by being
quizzed on the topic or maybe through
learning through conversation and that's
the one I'm going to go with today I
want to learn through conversation
so let's see can you explain to me what
a gene mutation is and how it differs
from a frame shift mutation
I actually
I want to understand
the role of RNA in gene mutations
we got some typos here y'all but that's
okay because we're human and it
understands
what is the role of RNA in gene
mutations
so it's able to help me understand that
it's talking me through it and now not
only is it giving me an explanation
absolutely RNA or ribonucleic acid plays
a crucial role in gene mutations and I
have this explanation but now it's
allowing me the opportunity to test my
understanding if a student were to ask
me how does a mutation in the DNA affect
the RNA how would I answer it so let's
say I'm not sure
can you give me some tips
[Music]
so it gives me a sample answer so we
have this very constructive back and
forth where as I'm building maybe my
understanding of the content because I'm
new to it or maybe just how I'm going to
explain it to students you know often
it's one thing to understand the content
ourselves it's a whole other thing to be
prepared to explain it to students at
that foundational level
so refresh my knowledge is a great tool
for that and just like I showed you
earlier you can even say
can you write that
as a poem
and it can do that
you could ask it to write a more
thorough explanation to expand or to
make something more concise
so it's really nice to have this safe
space to get that comfort and get that
confidence before we deliver content to
students
now let's say I've got that I'm feeling
pretty good about my comfort my
knowledge walking into that
I'm ready to start planning my lesson I
want to create a lesson hook for an
activity that I'm about to deliver
in this activity kamigo is going to help
us come up with some ideas for lesson
hopes to spark our students interest in
our lesson at the beginning of class
what grade level and subject am I
teaching so I'm going to shift just a
little bit and we're going to go into
teaching seventh grade
two-step equations
okay so it's going to come up with some
lesson hooks
let's see we've got one the magic number
box we would start the class by showing
them a decorated box tell the students
that the box contains a magic number the
only way to discover the number is
solving a two-step equation that we've
written on the board the surprise
element of the magic number will pique
their curiosity and they'll be eager to
solve the equation it's one idea we have
another idea that there's two now let's
say you know I really wanted something
more in tune with my students interests
and More in line with something that's
going to grab their attention right out
of the gate my students Junior High
teacher here my students love fortnite
so I'm going to ask can you
write lesson hooks
that are related to
fortnite let's see what we get
ah fortnite now that's a game that gets
kids excited it sure is so we've got a
fortnight Loot drop fortnite Battle
Royale you know about fortnite Battle
Royale is a big thing and so as soon as
I put this on the board as soon as I
tell students we're gonna do a battle
royale now they're listening to me right
now I've grabbed their inches this is
something that they're interested in
whether you were looking for a lesson
hook about Legos video games Pokemon
whatever the thing of the day is right
because it's always changing it's really
nice to have this alignment something
that students are interested in so it
grabs their interest and keeps their
interest in the lesson material so we've
got our lesson hooks let's think now
about how we're going to close the
lesson we've taught our lesson how are
we going to know whether or not students
really got a solid grasp of this
material
so we're going to write some exit ticket
questions what grade level and subject
do I want questions for
let's stick with seventh grade
two-step equations
all right what is a specific learning
objective let's see we're going to be
solving two step equations
with rational coefficients
[Music]
all right let's see what we get
so we had a few sample exit ticket
questions there and what I want to point
out is these aren't super complex you
could have made these right we can
always go and make our own exit ticket
questions we can go curate some examples
from the Internet or from our textbook
but saving the time to do that having
this done and at our fingertips is
really where the power of this is right
so that again as Diana mentioned at the
beginning
we're trying to take the time and the
burden away from those more arduous
tasks so that you can focus on the
students What If instead of curating
this material you're sitting at the
table working with a student or you're
actually working through these with kids
that's what we want to make sure you can
do
so we have five examples here of what
exit ticket questions might be
but I think the most powerful part of
this is it's not just about the
procedural fluency to be able to answer
these questions
what's almost more important is not
really have the not just that we have
the competence but that we have the
confidence in this content so we're also
given a couple of questions that gauge
students confidence and understanding on
a scale of one to five how confident are
they feeling
are they ready to take this forward can
they explain that's critically important
so having these questions again
available and at your fingertips is
super important
so with that we are going to shift
back over here and take a look at what
it might look like to use conmigo with
students so I want to really reinforce
one thing
unless you are part of a district
partnership where your school district
has said we are working with Khan
Academy and all of our teachers are
working as part of that then your
students will not have access to conmigo
on their own meaning they're not going
to be able to open their laptop and have
conmigo there on the screen now should
your District choose to explore a
district partnership with us which we do
have it does come with Comprehensive
robust support for setting you as a
teacher and your students as Learners up
for success with lots of PD that
actually looks a lot like this
but that may not be where you are right
now maybe you're just looking at what
would it look like for me as a teacher
to use this tool in my classroom if I'm
the only one that has it and we can
still look like look at what it might
look like to use this whole class again
think about projecting onto the
Whiteboard or pulling it up on a smart
board that's our frame of reference for
the next few minutes so think about what
it would look like whole class one
computer and we're working together
when we are talking to students about AI
when we're working with students in AI
it is critical that we frame the role of
AI in our classroom
it is a tool not a crutch it is a tool
amongst other tools we have in our
classroom manipulatives notes wall
charts rulers we have so many tools and
we choose the right tool for the job but
the most important thing is that our
brain
is our first supercomputer and we have
to reinforce that with students
conmigo is a tool to support our
thinking to support our learning not
replace it it's not something that we're
going to go to every time we have a
question our first line of defense is
always thinking critically for ourselves
and using conmigo as one of the tools in
our toolbox
so let's think about what it might look
like to use conmigo whole class
so I want to go back to
what it would look like
to use in one of the courses so I'm
going to go back to that middle school
biology course
go into one of the units
let's see let's pick a different piece
of content let's go to cell parts and
function
so here if I open up we're going to do
this activity we're learning about cell
parts and functions in class and I open
conmigo up
and I have it in student mode
imagine that we asked conmigo to help us
solve this
now remember this is up on the smart
board or on the Whiteboard
and conmigo is now talking to your
students because they can all see it
sure the goal is to pick the true facts
about the cell membrane do you know what
a cell membrane does so now let's
imagine I asked my students what's the
cell membrane do we have some hands pop
up what do you want to say to conmigo
and I have a friend back there in the
back road that says the cell membrane
keeps out the bad stuff so I say okay
I'm gonna type that in
the cell membrane
keeps out the bad stuff let's see what
it says
yep that's part of it the cell main cell
membrane does help keep out some things
but it but does it keep out all things
or just some
again you can ask your students what
does it do so a student might say I
think it lets some stuff in
and some stuff it keeps out
and we can keep going back and forth now
could we have the same discussion whole
class without conmigo absolutely could
we read about this in a book absolutely
but we're always looking for new ways to
engage students right if you pulled this
up on the board how might your students
react to this to having this back and
forth into having a tool where they can
contribute to a class discussion and
conmigo can have that back and forth
dialogue with your whole class we know
how important it is to change up the
voice right they maybe
you know we're looking for a different
perspective not listening to our
colleagues anymore looking for a
different voice than the teacher kamigo
can be really powerful for that and it
enables you again as the teacher to take
that guiding and facilitating role which
is the most powerful role for you
because you're leading that instruction
so that's one possibility
I'm going to go back to the AI
activities page
I'm going to scroll down here below our
teaching tools
we have some student tools and again
remember your students don't have this
one-to-one on their laptops but I want
you to think about how this might fit
into your existing instructional routine
so do your students ever have to craft a
story
do you have high school students that
are working on admissions essays or
maybe they need to check for problems in
their admission essay debate
what about historical figures let's say
that we're in history class and we are
learning about World War II I'm going to
open up historical figures and
Let's see we have Winston Churchill here
I'm going to open up Winston Churchill
again we're on the Smart Board we'd love
to meet Winston Churchill history is not
every student's favorite topic right A
lot of times we're stuck reading history
out of the book now we know this isn't
really Winston Churchill and of course
we're going to reinforce that to our
students this is Khan Migo speaking as
if it is Winston Churchill but now we're
bringing history to life
so ah Splendid Choice conmigo says I am
now about to become an AI simulation of
Winston Churchill so let's see I might
ask what was your
opinion
of D-Day oops
[Music]
a pivotal moment in the course of the
second World War
so we can have that back and forth right
how might this bring topics to life for
your students what is this going to do
to the engagement level in your history
class or in your history lesson if
you're in a self-contained classroom
and I want to go back up look at all the
different historical figures that you
could bring to life in your classroom
and engage students in a brand new way
in a way we've never been able to do
before
what about the same thing for literature
we might talk to a literary character
maybe we want to talk to Jay Gatsby and
ask so what's that green light really
all about right
always Chasing The elusive green light
now what brings you to my humble abode
is there a particular topic you'd like
to discuss or perhaps a question you've
been longing to ask
I'm gonna ask how did you really
feel about Daisy
foreign
Daisy old sport so even talking like Jay
Gatsby again think about the engagement
with the text we're gonna we're gonna
read the book right we need to work our
way through one of the greatest pieces
of literature of all time but now we can
really engage and get students thinking
more deeply and more critically than
they would have otherwise because we're
pulling this tool up on the smart board
up on the Whiteboard and engaging with
students in this brand new way
lots of other tools here word architect
word safari or even ignite my curiosity
students have Curiosities right there's
lots of things they want to know about
let's see my students I want to talk
about igniting our curiosity about
movies
because like movies everybody likes
movies right
let's explore something related to
movies like The Art of Storytelling or
the science of sound and Light
I want to know about the history
[Music]
of Cinema
so imagine bringing these topics to life
there really there's so many different
possibilities and ways that you can do
this but as a teacher you not only have
access to those teacher tools
but you also have access to the student
tools and there are ways even if you're
not part of a district partnership to
again engage students whole class and
that is important to think about because
if we are engaging students whole class
we're maintaining that safety we are
never putting AI in the hands of
students where we don't have those
safety mechanisms in place and those
safety protocols that are very much a
part of a district partnership and we
will give you some information in just a
few minutes about how to explore those
District Partnerships
one other thing I want to show you is
that you can also as a teacher chat with
dpt4 now we've all heard about dpt4 but
inconmigo
and a specifically designed to engage
with you as a teacher
so let's say
with chat gpg4
I need a letter
to parents
introducing
my new unit of study on 8th grade gene
mutations
it's going to help me draft that letter
now I have some students in my class and
their parents first language is Spanish
so I'm going to ask can you rewrite
that letter in Spanish
and there we go
I can even I can go back I can have it
back and forth I can make modifications
let's see I'm going to ask it to
how powerful right the letter is already
done in Spanish so I'm opening the door
to my family's no matter what their
first language is English Spanish they
are now empowered and this is fully
designed to support students English
Spanish and Portuguese
so let's see can you add a note
about a group project
that is oops that is due on November 1st
and it's going to do that I'll get it to
put it back in English in just a second
but we see that we can have that back
and forth and then all I have to do is
copy and paste and it's done how long
would it have taken us to write that
letter
otherwise right it's done and it's
really empowering to have that time
saved
you write this in English
so we can go back and forth and we have
it all at our fingertips
so I love this because again the
objective here is to take some of that
day-to-day planning and prep work off of
your plate so you have more time to
focus on instruction and to focus on
students and you can see here that we do
have that note the project will be a
sign on the first day of the unit and
the due date will be November 1st so now
all I have to do is copy this I could
paste it into a Word document make a
couple of changes if I wanted to and my
letter is done in less than five minutes
so with that I know we are still working
through the Q a if you have questions
post them in there I'm going to go ahead
and turn this back over to diona
thank you Stacy so after hearing all
that amazing information if you want to
learn more we highly encourage you to
visit our Khan Academy website where you
are going to find our con for educators
course inside of.com for educators
course there is a unit that talks about
uh conmigo and so Stacy is bringing that
up as well you will find you will find
it um as I said on our Khan Academy
um on our Khan Academy website
there's also a course that we have
called AI for educators
you can also learn more by uh going
through that course as well so we highly
encourage you to check both of those out
I'm going to add this course you guys it
is fantastic and it only takes like 30
45 minutes these articles super easy to
read really empowering and gave me a lot
of great ideas to really encourage you
to do that so as we wrap up just think
now imagine having a co-teacher at your
fingertips
24 7. you know sometimes I used to be up
late planning and my colleagues were not
there and so conmigo will be there to
help you with that if you want to track
your students progress as Stacy showed
you conmigo has you covered if you need
a help in your lesson planning conmigo
has a wide range of activities and Stacy
only hit on a couple of them so
um you are able to have that as well and
then kamigo just adapts and grows with
you so what what you see here on the
screen is there is a link there on how
you can try uh if you want to try
conmigo but don't worry about trying to
get that link after this presentation
there is going to be a follow-up email
for all of you that have registered and
so you will receive an email with this
link as well as a few more resources
so with that we definitely appreciate
your time if you have um any questions
as Stacy said make sure you put them in
a q a thank you for your time
thank you everyone have a great
afternoon we're so glad you came